but it's seattle again too we got to
talk about them i feel like we've talked
about your minnesota vikings more than
we've talked about the winning football
team well yeah seattle and just
they're unreal the car they're the
cardiac kids it just is they're never
phased by any situation oh we're down by
seven at home oh here they come they're
coming back
they just find ways to win football
games i love their little six down
offensive lineman front they have i mean
they're not playing a tight end right
now in some way with george fan in
motion did you see that yeah i mean it's
great big guy going in motion exactly
and they're basically just like hey up
yours we're gonna run the ball see if
you can stop it we got a whole bunch of
big efforts up here and we don't think
it really matters who you put down in
the box and they're controlling the
clock they're controlling the line of
scrimmage and then of course we know
when you get a little too antsy and
start worrying about the run game it's
zoo russell wilson time because he's got
three four receivers who were deadly
weapons in the past game and i don't
even think tyler lockett's 100 healthy
yet so seattle has found their mojo and
especially with the two-headed monster
of richard penny and chris carson man
that looks you know i mean that's that's
fun and dynamic they're both game
breakers uh in their own shape you know
own way but uh it was a fun game and
seattle is for real and they are a super
bowl team
and i think one of the reasons that they
they find a way to win these games it's
pete carroll is the head coach and it's
russell wilson at quarterback yeah and i
i want to be careful because we're going
to get some nasty text messages from uh
our coordinating producer if we say he
doesn't get enough credit but he doesn't
get enough credit he does not i mean
he here he is after the game russell
wilson talking about how the seahawks
always seemed to find a way to win games
like the one we saw last night
we have a winning culture
you got to have winning habits winning
just doesn't just happen you know
winning how you speak
you know the things you talk about think
how you work in the off season how you
work during the season uh winning is a
habit and uh um and so i think that uh
we we've learned how to how to win we
learn how to continue to win and that's
what this game is all about
yeah and it's funny i was watching the
game last night down in the barn and one
of the guys there said you know that guy
doesn't get enough credit i mean there
really is a sense out there that russell
wilson isn't viewed as
a top of the list one two three best
quarterbacks in the nfl insane just
isn't and he isn't i know it's insane
uh yes he is he's one of the three best
in the game right now there's i you know
maybe four okay if you want to go there
it's hey the top of the nfl the
quarterback position right now is it's
pretty damn talented i mean we got some
legitimate like mega superstars in him
and desean watson and mahomes and rogers
and lamar jackson so holy cow i mean
it's not easy to say you're number one
in that group but i'm with you first of
all his all-time quarterback rating is
up in the all-time ranks of the sport
he's special now i think the problem is
and why he doesn't get enough credit is
he's kind of a dork i mean that's just
the way it is i'm sorry i don't mean to
be mean like i respect the hell out of
russell wilson but i think that's how
he's viewed i don't care that he's a
dork but you saw how he's mic'd up in
the game last night and then like the
things he said let's go yeah hey let's
go oh we're gonna get good job he talks
like a coach he talks like a coach so
it's not like it's like uh a quarterback
that everybody's like oh he's talking
let me hear he's he's got coach talk go
he's always playing the role of
franchise quarterback whether he's in
the podium or he got a helmet on uh and
i think that kind of rubs people the
wrong way too because they go ah he's
kind of a dork he's not cool whatever
yeah whatever it is whatever because
between the lines he is a stud and he is
a man and uh i mean come on eight years
with a winning record his first eight
years in the nfl that's insane what he
does it really is and they went from a
defense to an offensive team and said
hey russell take over now and he's done
that ever since he's taken over and it
wasn't easy to play on the defensive
team as a quarterback like that so
i i do think he's a little bit
underappreciated by the masses yes
yeah uh and uh the seahawks as they have
retooled this team on the fly right see
you later to guys like richard sherman
and earl thomas cam chancellors was
injury driven but they've moved on from
guys who were the heart and soul of that
team when they won the super bowl and
and i remember last year when it was
starting to click for the seahawks i
talked to russell wilson after they beat
the lions 28-14 and he said it feels
like 2012 all over again yeah i said
does that make next year 2013. he said
we'll see right and and here they are
the number two seeds right now in the
nfc and it's quite possible the road to
miami is going to go through seattle and
uh that would set the table potentially
for the seahawks to uh to get back to
the super bowl and win it chris no no
doubt and last thing because i know we
got to go to commercial break but like
to what you're saying there that's where
pete carroll and john schneider deserve
a lot of credit i mean there are two gm
coach combination does it get really
many better than that in football i mean
to have the vision to get rid of some of
those superstars that made the seattle
seahawks who they are then to make
trades for clowny to make a trade for
quandary diggs holy cow is that paying
off i mean to draft dk metcalf at the
end of the second round you know josh
gordon bringing him on the squad that's
already helped out and come through in
some big moments i mean i think it's a
testament to them and how they run the
organization up there and that's why
they're so successful and they make it
all happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports